uh question here says I paid Zak more
than a week before
Eid is that valid question is if it is
not valid then what should I do as far
as giving Zak early is concerned all the
scholars all school of thought agree
that it should be given before the Salah
but how early can it be given can it be
given much earlier than that one week 2
weeks one month here the opinions of
different schools of thought differ as
well as Scholars according to the Maliki
and H schools of thought they say that
the earliest it can be given is one or
two days before Eid based on the Hadith
ofari Vol number two book of zakat Hadi
number 1511 where Omar Li with him he
said that people used to give zakat one
or two days before
Eid and further if it's a collector
who's collecting it based on the Hadith
of K when a person asks that when did
Omar with used to give zakat so the
reply was that after the collectors used
to collect when they used to collect the
reply is one or two days
before so that means while collecting
you can collect it a bit earlier and
there's another Hadith it's mentioned in
m
IM Malik volume number oneith number 630
it say that with him he used to send the
Z to the collectors two or three days
before Eid so here it shows that if
you're giving to a collector you can
give one two or three days maximum 3
days before the Eid according to the H
school of thought and Malik school of
thought based on the Hadith according to
the Han and the
shaf they say that it can be given in
any day during the month of Ramadan as
long as you finish the first day of
Ramadan because Z means purification of
the breaking of the fast as long as you
keep one fast after that it can be given
any time and but the people who collect
it can collect it and give it at the
right time so based on this you can give
any time of the month of
Ramadan there are some few Scholars who
say it can be given any time of the year
but the opinion is not correct it's very
weak but the right opinion is that if
given personally it should be given
before the E Salah before the people go
out for offering the Salah or can be
given on the eve of if it's given to a
collector it can be given one two or
three days before the Eid that's right
ruling if someone has given zakat one
week before and if he given directly to
the poor person it's not accepted he
should give it
again but if he give it to a
collector who will collect and give it
maybe on the eve of e Etc then he did
not give it again but if it's given to a
poor person directly one week before he
should give it again this is the right
truly Dr zakya thank you very much